Sallys Welt ist eine riesen Ehre dass du
heute hier dabei bist Hammer Torte
okay
okay ich habe die Challenge akzeptiert
es gibt für das Battle of the Socials
eine große Motivtorte von mir aktuell
weiß ich noch nicht wie sie aussehen
wird ich weiß noch nicht ganz wie sie
wird aber ich habe mir gedacht ich fange
jetzt einfach mal an Böden zu backen ich
habe tausende Zutaten da ich habe drei
Tage Zeit dafür
[Musik]
also hier ruhig jetzt gerade einen
mandelrühröl Boden mit Mandeln mit
Amaretto Sirup und das ganze backe ich
dann in drei 25 cm formen das wird die
mittlere Torte habe ich mir jetzt
einfach mal gedacht ich muss jetzt
einfach mal die Menge Backen
ausprobieren und dann gucken und wird
dann noch zwei weitere
Geschmacksrichtungen machen mal schauen
weil ich will ja immer dass meine Torten
nicht nur gut aussehen sondern halt auch
gut schmecken man sonst nicht im Leben
und dann mache ich noch energy Basis für
alle Fußballspieler und Spielerinnen
dass sie alle Energie geladen Fußball
spielen können
[Musik]
und vielleicht so eine große
email-schüssel so eine ganz große
[Musik]
farbe ist egal Hauptsache groß
Schüssel hat 6,9 Liter anscheinend hat
meine große Schüssel auch 6,9
litermaschine ne
das kriegen
du bist die Kondition ich bin
12 Jahre sind so viel für eine Maschine
plus 400 g Mandeln plus 1,2 kg
Flüssigkeit und so weiter geschafft
[Musik]
okay
Portion 1 kann im Backofen los geht's
mit
[Musik]
und Backofen draußen
ich habe ein paar Backofen
das sind unsere
ersatzbacköfen die wir immer haben wenn
wir was rein filmen wollen hier haben
wir noch zwei oben haben wir noch einen
und eigentlich haben wir noch in der
neuen Küche zwei aber die sind noch
nicht angeschlossen also beschränken wir
uns mal auf vier wird schon reichen okay
[Musik]
ich ich mag es einfach nicht Eier
aufzuschlagen ich muss mir da halt
danach sofort die Hände waschen und dann
habe ich mir irgendwann im Video
abgewöhnt weil ich dann jedes Mal
nachdem ich das gemacht habe Eier
Händewaschen gehen muss und deswegen
mache ich es einfach nicht so gerne im
Video
wobei ich mir manchmal dann denkt
vielleicht wissen manche Menschen nicht
wie man Eier richtig trennt und dann ist
es so
komisch wenn ich es nicht zeige wie ich
Eier aufschlage oder ist es okay wenn
ihr euch dran gewöhnt habt
ich finde halt wenn man in so Sendungen
Eier aufschlägt und dann sich danach die
Hände nicht möchte ich finde es einfach
eklig
[Musik]
die Zutaten auf die Seite räumen und
währenddessen für einen Backofen 20er
backen die passen auf einem Blech dann
spare ich den Backofen während das Back
kann ich dann in der Zeit aus dem
Backofen wenn die wieder raus sind die
zwei großen hier wieder machen draußen
habe ich
ich habe jetzt hier 123 25er jetzt mache
ich zwei 20er für draußen in der Zeit
wieder hier 220er und dann noch zwei
große
gell
[Musik]
ich habe echt nichts sagen aber ich
glaube heute brauchen wir echt alle
Maschinen hier so alles was im Haus hier
am kirchenmaschine
haben wir noch Öl das war jetzt der
dritte Flasche
danke danke
[Musik]
ich sehe schon auf mannheim24 der
Artikel
Sallys Welt gehen die Backformen aus
und um Waghäusel gibt es keine Eier mehr
wieso sind die butterpreise gestiegen
Böden vier und fünf
[Musik]
64 durch 100
mal 60 dann haben wir 38
38,4 weil dann backen wir zwei Bleche
und setzen uns aneinander
[Musik]
ich glaube ich Verbrauch genauso viel
Kalorien beim Backen wie die alle am
Sonntag beim Kicken hier
ich hätte einfach so just for the
feeling und Trikot anziehen können aber
weißt dann fühle ich mich sportlich
[Musik]
ich glaube mein backschrank war noch nie
so leer
so wenig Zutaten noch mache ich jetzt
Haselnuss schokoladenböden okay man kann
hier in meiner App ganz gut zum Glück
einfach die Zutaten umrechnen lassen und
ich mache es dann meistens so wenn ich
einen 30er bin habe 6,8 Eier gucke ich
halt dass ich so mache dass es acht Eier
sind mache ich her
Mama
[Musik]
aber so eine grobe Idee habe ich drei
Stücke ich
20 25 30 unten im Spielfeld
und den Rest überlege ich mir noch
[Musik]
was
ist
Daniela der backschrank ist fast nicht
ja aber es muss man auch mal schaffen
eine vierstöckige Torte aus Zutaten zu
backen die man einfach so in seinem
Küchenschrank hat oder
nein
[Musik]
und dann geht's morgen weiter mit dem
Füllen meiner vier Torten
von denen ich immer noch nicht weiß wie
sie aussehen
aber das schmeckt schon mal nach
Schokolade Kokos Mandel
ich gebe Butter kaufen
okay los geht's heute mit dem Torte
füllen habe jetzt hier zwei Kessel
Buttercreme
zwei sieben liter Kessel Buttercreme mal
gespannt wie lange die jetzt ausreichen
werden denn man muss ja schon sagen
keine Buttercreme ist auch keine Lösung
die sind jetzt hier schon fertig
angerührt jetzt schneide ich alle Böden
erstmal durch
also habe ich jetzt hier schon mal
meinen cakeboard darauf werde ich die
Torten stapeln das ist auch immer ganz
wichtig wenn ihr mehrstöckige Torten
macht immer auf den cakeboard dann kann
man sehr stapeln transportieren
wegstellen wiederherstellen ich lege
jetzt einfach mal los immer ein bisschen
Buttercreme zum kleben dann einen Boden
Marmelade
wenn ihr auch so große Torten plant und
backt und euch das ganze ein bisschen
erleichtern wollt könnt ihr auch die
Böden schon ein paar Tage vorher backen
Sie zuschneiden und dann einzeln
einfrieren am besten mit Backpapier
dazwischen wenn ihr dann nämlich die
Torte füllt gerade mit Buttercreme ist
der Vorteil dass sie die gefrorenen
Böden nehmt sie einstreicht der nächsten
Boden draufsetzt und die Buttercreme die
zieht sofort fest an klappt doch mit
Ganache und dann habt ihr keinen
zwischen step mit ich muss das nochmal
kühl stellen bis die Torte fest ist
sondern könnt die Torte direkt im
gleichen Schritt praktisch Klatsch
streichen und weiter verarbeiten es
folgt der gute Zeit Spartipp
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal eine 30 cm
sag jetzt wo hast du gesehen
ach stimmt ich habe eine gebacken
okay ich habe ja noch Böden 14 cm fehlen
noch das Problem ist dass bei so hohen
Torten die Tortenböden das nicht
aushalten also muss ich diese Torte in
sich
stabilisieren ich brauche
tortendübel aus dem Baumarkt also
Rundholz Rundholz zum reinmachen das
heißt für jetzt ist die Torte erstmal
gut die kommt in den Kühlschrank kann
zwischen kühlen
denn ich habe natürlich keine gefrorenen
Böden ich habe sie einfach nur kühl
gestellt
[Musik]
aber ihr könnt ja jetzt schon mal gerne
abschätzen was ihr zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt denkt was die Torte wiegen
wird
wenn ihr euch überlegt dass ich das
Spielfeld gebacken habe und eins zwei
drei Stockwerke drüber was glaubt ihr
was wiegt die Torte und am Ende könnt
ihr noch mal abschätzen so erste Meinung
zweite Meinung
und der oder die die am nächsten dran
sind
die bekommen dann die bekommen dann und
backpaket das heißt ich werde am Ende
nicht verraten sondern weil es dann
irgendwann in dem short oder so
aufklären
das machen wir mal die untere Torte
Schokolade die werde ich jetzt füllen
ich habe jetzt 1,5 Kilogramm Buttercreme
abgewogen
da kommen 200g Saat Bitterschokolade
rein 200 g Vollmilchschokolade das wird
verrührt ist schon mal eine krasse
Mischung
und dann willst du probieren
[Gelächter]
und dann wird dieser Schoko
haselnussboden mit dieser Schokocreme
gefüllt plus
Kekse zerbröseln und damit reingeben für
den einzigartigen Kleber kannst du bitte
dem Memo schreiben ob er beim Baumarkt
eine Holzplatte kaufen kann kriegen wir
62 in den Kühlschrank ja 62 mal
40 1 cm dick er soll aber auch noch eine
holen 2 cm dick Rundholz 1cm Durchmesser
weiß nicht wie lange die sind immer erst
einmal 10 Stück mitnehmen 8m runter
und sechs Meter
Rundholz 5 mm man muss es jetzt
übertreiben
[Musik]
muss ich noch mal Buttercreme muss ich
halt meine Ursprungs Aussage korrigieren
indem ich sage für diese Torte hier habe
ich drei Kilo Buttercreme mit 400 g
Zartbitterschokolade und 400 Gramm
Vollmilch Schokolade gemischt
da kommt jetzt mal
schrottenrandfolie drum Tortenring ab in
den Kühlschrank und dann geht's weiter
mit der andere
während die eine tortenhälfte kühlt kann
ich hier mit der anderen tortenhälfte
weitermachen das heißt die kleine Torte
oben drauf mit Kokos dafür habe ich
jetzt auch hier Buttercreme hier drauf
der erste Boden dann nehme ich hier
Aprikosen Fruchtaufstrich ich mache
immer so ein bisschen was fruchtiges
rein das schmeckt ganz gut dann die
Buttercreme und dann so ein paar
Schokoladenraspel mal Schokolade und
Kokos das passt auch ganz gut
[Musik]
also ich kann schon mal jetzt sagen ich
habe keine Ahnung an wen die Torte
verteilt werden ne also nicht später
hätten hier ich habe kein Stück
abgekriegt ich weiß es nicht umschlagen
ich sehe schon am Ende ist so eine
riesige Tortenschlacht im Stadion
[Musik]
also ich schätze die Torte ist
27 cm hoch
20 also 19 krass nee 20 genau
ich überlege mir mal wie die Torte
aussieht also oberes Stockwerk
in der Größe
[Musik]
das vergeht direkt mein Gefühl für die
Farbe bekommen
[Musik]
die Torte ist fertig
die 25 cm Torte ist jetzt gekühlt und
ich habe jetzt runter vom Baumarkt das
sind so ganz normale buchen Rundhölzer
und die brauche ich jetzt das muss man
sich jetzt so vorstellen wenn man so
eine große Torte Stapel schichtet
aufeinander setzen will muss man das
ganze wie beim Hausbau mit so Stäben
stabilisieren wieso Säulen und dann
kommt die nächste Platte drauf nur dann
kann es halten ansonsten er schlägt die
obere Masse die untere und alles bricht
zusammen und weil diese mittlere Torte
extrem hoch wird wegen dem ganzen Logo
vorne dran muss ich sie in sich schon
mal stabilisieren hat man das verstanden
ja ne also wenn ich jetzt mal runter
kommt hier rein das sind 1 cm runter
lebensmittelstift
dann ich hier
markieren
und einmal absägen und dann brauche ich
das hier dreimal
so wo ist meine Säge hier
direkt die Katze fertig
[Musik]
damit er einfach nichts passieren kann
und noch mal abwaschen natürlich falls
ihr so wie ich gerade kein Schleifpapier
zur Hand habe nimmt einfach die Scheiben
vom Exzenterschleifer es geht genau so
welche hatte ich jetzt die 60
auch
okay ab damit in die Torte
perfekt
muss man natürlich später beim
Anschneiden bedenken
aber wenn die überzieht also die
verschluckt man jetzt nicht aus Versehen
okay ich mache jetzt so es muss jetzt
noch einen cakeboard dazwischen ist ein
bisschen größer als die Folie also kommt
die Torte kurz im Kühlschrank ich werde
auf dem cakeboard hier die Torte noch
mal höher aufbauen so viel wie ich
brauche und setze es dann einfach drauf
jetzt kommen die zwei eckigen Torten
hier drauf
das Spielfeld
und immer ein bisschen Creme damit es
nicht verrutscht
hier ist die Mitte
[Musik]
C
aber irgendwann am Ende des Tages ist es
vorbei also ich mache es jetzt so die
Torten sind jetzt eigentlich alle
gefüllt mich noch ein bisschen um
Fondant und um die Icons und dann reicht
es für heute dann gehe ich in die Heia
das wird schon fertig werden
oder
[Musik]
so
ich mache jetzt gerade die social media
icons aus Fondant ich habe hier einfach
von dann verschiedenen Farben das tiktok
Twitch
YouTube und was fehlt Instagram und
instagram ist sehr schön bunt deswegen
habe ich jetzt erstmal hier weiß
nur die schlauen Menschen sehen das
Instagram Symbol drauf
wie beides Kaisers neue Kleider ich
nehme jetzt Pulverfarbe
Lebensmittelfarbe und Pulver das jetzt
einfach so drüber ich habe leider dieses
lila nicht aber ich glaube ich löse es
mit blau
wusstest du wenn du Geld hier
draufstreust
dann etwas rot nehmen
die Diagonale
mit etwas pink auflockerst einen
trockenen Pinsel nimmst und drüber
wischst das dann das Instagram Logo
entsteht
[Musik]
neuer Tag neues Glück heute werden die
Torten fertiggestellt
erstmal alle schön glatt streichen erst
am Rand an der Oberfläche und am besten
mit Hilfe von ganaching Boards also
tatsächlich ist es oft so wenn man
Torten backt das Backen füllen und
einstreichen ist so viel Arbeit dass die
Deko oft zu kurz kommt aber bei unserer
Torte darf die Deko auch nicht zu kurz
kommen natürlich
[Musik]
ich habe mir was überlegt diese Torte
kommt hier drauf ich habe hier die Dübel
drin weil ich dann die Torte draufsetzen
kann ohne dass es ein sagt jetzt ist mir
noch eine Idee gekommen dass das Ganze
stabil steht muss ich oder möchte ich
einen Stab praktisch von oben bis unten
durchstechen das auch nichts mehr
verrutscht bedeutet für mich
dass ich ein cakeboard nehme und es
durchbohrer
ignoriert einfach die Unordnung okay wir
sind gerade im Küchenumbau
[Musik]
fertig
und durch die Spitze geht die Torte
nicht kaputt
minimal
[Musik]
hoffe dass das jetzt die finale Schicht
ist
wenn ich alles richtig gut gemacht habe
und die Torte gut gekühlt ist ist das
jetzt die finale Schicht für den Rand
was gibt's hier zu beachten ich streiche
immer gerne die Creme von unten nach
oben
herum bisschen mehr als es braucht und
dann habe ich genug Material um es dann
abzuziehen schauen wir mal wie gut ich
gearbeitet habe
[Musik]
schon mal nicht schlecht ich kühl sie
jetzt
und perfektionierte dann
aber so sieht sie schon
ich nutze jetzt mal die Zwischenzeit und
mache hier die Icons und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier weißen Fondant mit der
lasagnewalze weil sich jetzt meine
Fondant dünn aus und mit der Fettuccine
Walze schneide ich ihn zu dann habe ich
schöne gleichmäßige Streifen für zum
Beispiel das instagram-symbol
ich nehme einfach immer hier diese
Schablone und dann schneide ich sie zu
und kann genau exakt die Größe da drauf
machen ja
[Musik]
Punkt Punkt Komma Strich fertig ist das
Mondgesicht
[Musik]
wir nehmen jetzt Schablonen arbeitet und
sie halten nicht so gut nimmt die
einfach etwas backtrennspray
kommt auf die Oberfläche das trocknet
ihr später einfach wieder weg
und dann könnt ihr eure Papier Schablone
ein bisschen befestigen
[Musik]
bleibt noch instagram
instagram
aufräumen und weitermachen
hier gerade drei Kilo schwarzen Fondant
Fan aber es ist okay und ich werde jetzt
damit der Stress in meinem Kopf aufhört
zuerst die höchste und große Torte damit
überziehen und ich habe noch nie so eine
riesige so eine Torte überzogen das
heißt die dann Durchmesser von 25 cm
dann kommen jeweils 30 cm noch dazu
bisschen Puffer also muss ich ja schon
von hier bis da von hier die Decke
ausrolle
reicht es drei Kilo
[Musik]
das reicht doch niemals
wieso Pizza
[Musik]
es tut einfach nur noch weh guck meine
Arme sind rot
fehlen jetzt rechts und links und oben
unten noch 20 cm
dann nehme ich jetzt aber schon mal die
Schokotorte
und überzieht die damit
für die müssten
und die mittlere brauchen halt noch mehr
müssen wir sechs Kilo oder so kneten
backtrennspray drauf
und Papa
Falten weg
ist echt bewusst dass es erst die erste
Torte ist die ich überziehe und ich noch
drei weitere habe darunter ein Spielfeld
ein Fußballspielfeld
1,8 Kilo
1,8 Kilo habe ich übrig das heißt die
Torte hat 1,2 kg überzogen
läuft
naja ihr habt doch nicht gedacht ich
knete 9 kg Fondant allein
jetzt perfekt
also jetzt momentan könnte es auch noch
eine schwarze Hochzeitstorte werden
plus
490 sind 2830
also viel mehr also deswegen ist
Mathematik so wichtig
die 30 cm Torte hat 1,2 Kilogramm von
Sand auf sich und dann reichen
aber ich muss noch das Drumherum Rechner
was ich als Zusatz brauche dann würde
ich sagen beim 3 Kilo gemacht aber mal
fünf
und dann wäre ich ungefähr auf der Torte
1,
5 6
und eine gute Armmuskulatur
der knossi hat gesagt Sally ich habe
doch so Event kannst du nicht kommen und
head of Sweets machen okay
jetzt stehe ich damit neun Kilo Fondant
und es wird nett weich
und immer noch weiter und es wird immer
noch nicht weich
hin
[Musik]
Fondant ein
also das steht größte Fondant Platte die
ich je mit eigener Kraft ausgerollt habe
ich will es mal nur sagen der hat einen
Durchmesser von über einem Meter
und wieso rechts im Kühlschrank nach
Pups
wir machen kurz Teamwork Daniela ich
nehme die Decke hoch du ziehst die Matte
Weg Holger du schiebst die Torte weiter
rein ja
okay
Fondant überzogen
[Applaus]
mit vollem Körpereinsatz kann man so
sagen
Wrestling 2.0
[Musik]
Action verpasst hier ich habe liebevoll
denn Fondant ausgegangen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der Fondant auf die Torte
und hier ist immer wichtig erst die
Ecken formen dann hier die Ecke und dann
am Rand glatt streichen
[Musik]
gerade hoffe ich ich mache jetzt hier
noch die Hashtags Team Lena Team Jonas
untere Torte mit drauf kommt
und das steche ich jetzt hier einfach
mit Buchstaben mal
sagen ich bin schon ziemlich
Fett
[Musik]
so machen wir jetzt mal ein Spielfeld
hier draußen natürlich weiß ich nicht
wie ein Fußballfeld aussieht auswendig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also drei Tage später
bin ich jetzt so alt
drei Torten vier ein grünes Spielfeld
die drei Torten
ich muss euch eins sagen das habe ich
jetzt drucken lassen in so einer
Tortenbild Druckerei ich wollte
eigentlich ausschneiden zum hier drauf
kleben aber nett das schaffe ich nicht
das schaffen ich schaffe es natürlich
schon aber ich habe die Zeit nicht mehr
und die Nerven auch nicht mehr hier habe
ich die Spieler die Kapitäne wow womit
fange ich jetzt an zusammensetzen kann
ich sie erst vor Ort das heißt ich sehe
erst vor Ort ob alles geklappt hat ich
muss jetzt auf jeden Fall in die und die
Torte noch die Dübel machen damit ich
das vor Ort stapeln kann in die Torte
natürlich auch jetzt klebe ich hier noch
Creator Cup battle of the Socials auf
diese Torte
ja und dann klebe ich die Team Lena
Sachen und so weiter hier unten und
vielleicht zwei auch da oben machen wir
zwei unten zwei oben weil dann kann ich
die einzelnen Spieler später so zack
zack zack in die Torte
[Musik]
warum habe ich hier nicht einfach eine
kapsäge wisst du warum habe ich ja wenn
du einfach eine Kappsäge
dann ist jetzt die letzte Torte auch
fertig ich packe jetzt alle in den
Kühlschrank und dann fahren wir damit
nach Mainz
ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
bevor man so eine große Torte backt
sollte man sich natürlich auch immer
überlegen wie transportiere ich diese
Torte vor dieser Herausforderung stehen
wir
ich habe aber extra einen Transporter
die ist einfach zu schwer für mich
okay
sie ist sehr schön okay
[Musik]
ja schau dir das mal an müsste nur
einmal ungefähr vorstellen
und los geht's
also wir haben es geschafft wir sind
schon in Mainz angekommen die grüne
Torte ist schon mal heil geblieben die
anderen weiß es nicht wir machen gleich
die Transportbox
[Musik]
en haben extra für die Torte gekauft
sowas machen ich glaube sie hat überlebt
was was nein ich habe es vorher gesagt
oh mein Gott wir haben noch gesagt wer
weiß ob die Spiel ob die genauso
gegeneinander spielen Lena gegen jonas
war das erste Spiel was es auf meiner
ersten Torte drauf Lena gegen Jonas
mein Problem ist gerade nur ich will sie
jetzt noch nicht komplett zusammenbauen
weil die halt 45 Kilo wiegt und ich weiß
nicht ob die untere Torte das Gewicht
der oberen Torte packt deswegen setzt
sich vielleicht nur die drauf
ich habe noch eine Ganache gemacht was
das Ganze Fußballspiel Leute ich habe
eine Ganache vorbereitet und damit setze
ich das drauf das ist später nicht
rutscht damit es schön durch die Kälte
festklebt und später nicht auf dem
Spielfeld ich stolper und dann macht so
Blut und alle Torten fliegen
gerade vorne
ohne Torte schwer das ist wirklich keine
drin ja
da hoch komm an Mama okay
ich trag die Torte und du die
Verantwortung
sie hat überlegt
die so schön
das packt man nicht
okay dann packe ich jetzt einfach mal
alles da drauf alles kommt in den
Kühlraum und später kurz vor dem
Servieren bitte zusammengesetzt gut
so aber kühl das schon mal gut
[Musik]
okay wir haben es geschafft aber wir
müssen uns beeilen ich muss jetzt im
Fahrstuhl die Spieler noch drauf machen
ist richtig voll oh mein Gott
die wackelt einfach brutal
[Gelächter]
so aufregend waren tortentransport echt
noch nie jetzt sind nur noch wenige
Meter
aber ich bin fix und fertig ich fahre
gleich um
sind hier auch noch 15.000 Menschen im
Stadion
Schild Sally kommen wieder runter
ist eine riesen Ehre dass du heute hier
dabei bist bei diesem Event keine Torte
gemacht
unorganisiert waren cooles Event in
stolz auf euch
let's dance
[Musik]
okay
Hammer Torte
[Musik]
gemacht Leute
super damit du die ganze Nacht feiern
können
[Applaus]
[Musik]